David how are you this morning I'm doing
excellent fellows always great to be on
the show with you guys how are your DP
we're doing well how would you sum up
that game last night I mean you know if
you talk about the whole Giants mantra
ever since coach McAdoo has taken over
you know they've talked about discipline
poise determination focus those were
things that have been lacking not only
in this game but in the last three games
because if you think about those things
they've had 22 penalties in the last
three games they've had three turnovers
three turnovers and two turnovers in the
last three games so a total of eight and
the penalties that they had last night
on the road in Minnesota absolutely
killed all of their momentum because
they punted the ball the first five
possessions of the games because they
were in third and 8 3rd and 10 third and
8 3rd and 10 when you're in a tough
position on the road playing up against
a good defense like that you can't give
them that much momentum to where they
have flexibility on third down to do
everything that they've done scheme wise
because if you really watched it because
of the fact that they were able to put
the Giants in third and long positions
they only rushed for maybe five and they
were able to drop either Harrison Smith
or Anthony Barr and drop them into
coverage to cut off the quick and
intermediate routes by the Giants
receivers that Vikings defenses look
really really good so far this season
but is it is that Vikings defense built
for the long haul this season I believe
that it is I mean it's no coincidence
they took over this year right after
where they were last season because they
have every single starter back and if
you think about the last six
quarterbacks they faced or i should say
seven because you can put eli manning
and aaron rodgers in those twice
including playoffs those quarterbacks
have had six touchdowns and they've had
12 interceptions and that's twice Aaron
Rodgers twice Eli Manning Russell Wilson
Cam Newton Marcus Mariota so they're
performing at a high
level up against elite quarterbacks and
they're able to do it with the recipe
for success for any team when you're
able to get pressure on the quarterback
with four and work back you get back
into different coverages and schemes
like they were last night I mean that
that's everything for a football team
not to mention once again providing more
sparks on decent and on special teams
going into last night's game they were
the only team in the NFL with the fumble
return and interception return and a
punt return for a touchdown and look at
what happened I'm getting that part of
that punt return I'll by Dwayne Harris
by fumbling it it gave the Minnesota
offense perfect field position where
they basically walked in for a touchdown
so are those those things when your
defense your special teams are giving
your often so much more opportunities to
control the clock control the tempo of
the football game I mean that's
everything that's perfect for sam
bradford's game talking to David Diehl
former Giants lyman NFL on Fox analyst
are we making too much of Odell
Beckham's temperament you know what I'm
all about being excited being emotional
and throughout my 11 years playing in
the NFL and now the last recovering them
I've seen blow ups on the sidelines I've
seen meltdowns but when it happened last
week and then you have it happen this
week and you have teammates starting to
react to it you have people pulling you
off to the side then it becomes a
reaction and then it becomes a
distraction because you're talking about
it still now today when the focus should
be out on the football game and if you
really think about it last night he had
23 yards receiving and he had one
penalty for 15 yards as a elite wide
receiver in NFL when they need you to
make the big play and you're having the
drops on third down like you had in the
game last night and in the previous
games I understand that you feel that
you're unfairly targeted but number one
the rule is made up for you it is called
the Odell Beckham jr. rule you know that
they're going to be paying attention to
you know the cameras are going to be on
you focusing on you each and every time
having said that do I think Xavier
Rhodes should have gotten a penalty for
the things that he was doing yes he was
taunting him he was hitting them and
doing extracurricular stuff but that's
going to happen every single
weekend for the rest of the year because
they feel that that's the way to get
Odell Beckham jr. out of the game that
gets the Giants offense out of sync and
it makes other players have to worry
about getting and talking to Odell
onside yeah I love the enthusiasm but he
has to understand he's so good that if
he gets into it with somebody else he he
brings himself down to their level there
aren't many defensive backs who are
capable stopping him one-on-one aren't
many defensive backs is talented as him
but when you allow them to get into your
head now you've come down to their level
that's the bigger concern I have I love
that you play with passion and I do know
that you know everybody realizes being a
wide receiver is a selfish position
they're all about themselves they're
they're in their own little battle
individual war and they don't worry
about the overall war sometimes and I
think that's where Odell Beckham is
getting priorities and you know they're
there they're not lining up the way they
should no they shouldn't and when you
have these flare ups and these things
happen it's because you are not
producing and playing the way that
you're capable of playing I mean that's
a given and like I said the fact that he
is being followed and this is continuing
to happen it is no coincidence because
players have seen the way that you've
reacted and if you go back to that
Washington game they saw the way that
Weston Richburg reacted by going in Josh
Norman elated that completely changed
the outcome of that football game so it
is a direct reflection of what is taking
place and it is trickling through the
rest of the team currently good stuff
David great to talk to you and hope see
again some sometime soon absolutely
thanks for having me fellas always great
be an IVP thank David deal former Giants
lemon NFL on Fox analyst the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience